Speaker 1: All right, this this is really
beyond belief. Donald Trump has written
a book written is not actually the right
word, and it is literally a picture book.
You know, all those jokes about Trump's
executive orders are written in crayon.
Trump's presidential library would be pictures
of tweets and then like the not jokes like. For
example, Trump's presidential daily briefing was
a single page, double spaced, mostly pictures and
charts. That was true. Trump has done what many
former presidents do, which is he made a book,
not wrote a book, made a book, but it is a literal
picture book with pictures and descriptions of the
pictures written apparently by Trump, which read
like his old tweets. You just have to see this.
Donald Trump Jr. tweeting about it. Excited,
saying huge news. A new book by President Donald
Trump is being published coming out next month.
Our journey together a beautiful 300+ page color
coffee table style. Read all about it. Guys,
it's it's a picture book. The Washington Examiner
writes about it and it. They include some pictures
from the book, I guess you would say. And like,
for example, I'm describing this to to our audio
audience. There's a picture of Trump sitting in
the Oval Office with Nancy Pelosi and the caption,
which I guess it's really the writing. It says,
attempting to listen to crazy Nancy Pelosi in
the Oval Office. Such natural disagreement.
Many presidents write books, Trump has done a
picture book with captions that are insults of
people. Another picture this is the picture that
we now know was a staged picture from the White
House. I believe it's the Situation Room. We know
that this picture was staged and it says the night
we got Abu Bakr al Baghdadi, we destroyed ISIS
under my watch. Now terrorists are back in the
Middle East, so this one's in it. This picture
is an insult of Joe Biden. When we since learned
this picture was staged, Trump was actually,
I believe, playing golf at the relevant time.
One more example, Trump sitting alongside
German Chancellor Angela Merkel and then
British Prime Minister Theresa May and the caption
is an insult to Theresa May were Trump wrote
meeting with German Chancellor and
British Prime Minister Theresa tried hard
but didn't get the job done. Boris Johnson
is much better for the United Kingdom.
And then just like kind of family pictures
of different kinds, you really couldn't write
this stuff, guys. I mean, this is it's we talk
about Trump being sort of semi-literate in the
sense that we know he hasn't read a book in
decades, at least maybe in his entire adult
life. We know that his writing was very strange
and compromised. And so even in doing what just
about every president does writing a book, it's
a picture book with the equivalent of his tweets
insulting people. And of course, to sell it,
they say it's a coffee table style book. What it.
It's a picture book, guys. It's absolutely
insane. And even more maybe pathetic is that
this picture book got Trump an interview on Fox
News, which is what I want to talk about next.